en estos vídeos hemos platicado cómo le
podemos hacer para financiar una empresa
pero únicamente nos hemos enfocado en el
capital entonces déjame escribirle por
acá financiamiento
nanciamiento
y en realidad hay dos formas para
obtener dinero para seguir realizando
las operaciones de un negocio una que es
la que ya platicamos es justamente a
través de capital de capital
y la idea era muy sencilla nosotros
teníamos una empresa que estaba en
cierta etapa necesitamos dinero y
entonces buscamos a socios que quieran
formar parte de la compañía a los cuales
le damos algunas acciones para que
puedan pues hacer votaciones y que estén
involucrados con la administración y a
cambio ellos nos dan efectivo nos dan
así billetes para poder pagar nuestras
operaciones entonces el capital se hace
a través de acciones acciones acciones y
con las acciones pues pasaban una de dos
cosas o sea nos podía ir muy bien o nos
podía ir muy mal entonces si nos iba muy
mal lo voy a poner acá el caso en el que
nos va muy mal entonces todos estos
accionistas pues no ganaba nada aquí era
si callamos en bancarrota bancarrota
pero el lado bueno el lado positivo le
voy a poner el lado bueno el lado bueno
es que si a la empresa le iba bien
entonces si empieza a crecer y a ganar
mucho dinero estos accionistas obtienen
esos beneficios entonces me voy a poner
todos
obtienen beneficios beneficios entonces
esto era el financiamiento a través de
capital sin embargo hay otra forma de
financiarse que es un poco más común
entre los hogares bueno no se han
derivado entre los hogares podría
financiarse con capital pero así no
funciona la cosa verdad no es como que
vas con tu vecino o con tu mejor amigo y
le dices ay no te quieres unir a la
compañía que es mi casa y te doy
acciones y eres parte pues de esta
comunidad y puedes tomar decisiones de
familia no como que eso es muy raro
verdad así no funciona el financiamiento
de las casas usualmente lo que se hace
es pedir un préstamo en el banco
entonces la otra forma de financiarse
justo es a través de deuda de deuda
y pues una deuda prácticamente es pedir
prestado dinero sí o sea vas con un
banco y le dices al banco yo necesito
dinero o le dices a tu amigo oye
necesito 100 pesos y en un año te voy a
pagar 120 y tu amigo te dice bueno va
este yo sé que tú me vas a pagar porque
vas más o menos bien con tu trabajo así
que yo te los puesto entonces aquí
tenemos en este caso
y un financiamiento a través de deuda es
un préstamo por el cual hay que pagar
intereses y qué sucede en este caso o
sea como como está representada la deuda
pues ahora no es a través de acciones
sino a través de digamos un pagaré
oa través de un bono bono es un poco más
formal y qué sucede si le va bien o si
le va mal a la empresa pues la cosa con
la deuda es que bueno si a la empresa le
empieza a ir bien nada más tiene que
pagar los intereses que acordó digamos
como del 7% si entonces la empresa va a
un banco pide un préstamo bancario
digamos va con bancomer y le dice sabes
que necesito 20 millones de pesos y
entonces pues ya pide el préstamo tiene
que pagar intereses y aunque le vaya muy
muy bien el banco no recibe más que ese
7% va por otro lado si a la empresa le
va mal si cae en bancarrota entonces lo
voy a poner aquí bancarrota bancarrota
de todas formas el banco sigue
recibiendo 7% entonces bueno la cosa es
que con un financiamiento por deuda
tiene la empresa la ventaja de que no
paga en más y le va muy bien pero si le
va mal de todas formas tiene que pagar
ese 7% entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo
un poco más concreto vámonos a una hoja
de balance lo voy a hacer aquí al lado
para que veamos cómo puede funcionar
esto de el financiamiento a través de
deuda entonces voy a poner aquí una hoja
de balance
más o menos algo así ahí tenemos activo
de este lado tenemos el capital
supongamos que hasta ahorita no hay nada
de deuda que es lo que hemos estado
poniendo todo el tiempo y pues podemos
pensar que la compañía es pública o que
es privada pero ahorita vamos a pensar
que es pública porque quiero contarte
una cosa que no hemos platicado a ver
déjame escribirlo por otro lado porque
voy a ocupar ese espacio la compañía es
pública vale y entonces como la compañía
es pública ahora podemos saber
fácilmente cuánto vale la empresa porque
osea antes teníamos que pasar por
ciertas evaluaciones latosas para poder
recurrir a más capital porque al
principio con el inversionista ángel y
con los primeros capitalistas de riesgo
pues tenían que hacer muchos análisis y
evaluaciones previas sin embargo ahorita
ya tenemos una herramienta que nos
permite saber cuánto vale nuestra
empresa muy rápidamente como la empresa
ya es pública entonces la empresa está
enlistada en la bolsa mexicana de
valores bolsa mexicana de valores le voy
a poner el puntito verde aquí y como ya
está enlistada en la bolsa mexicana de
valores y tiene un cierto símbolo
vamos a ponerle tiene un símbolo simple
entonces con ese símbolo ya puedes
buscar pues en internet así en la página
que tú quieras en tu página favorita de
finanzas mientras finanzas o lo que sea
y puedes ver la gráfica del precio una
gráfica de precio de una acción se ve
más o menos así déjame pintar por acá un
eje luego por acá otro eje por su estilo
más o menos algo así
voy a ponerlo con color amarillo y se ve
más o menos algo de este estilo es esta
el precio empieza a tener altibajos
luego sube luego puedes subir un poco
más y luego bajar de repente
algo de este estilo entonces esta
gráfica nos da una información
instantánea del precio de la empresa y
bueno a lo mejor bueno no sé si podrías
cuestionarte un poquito si realmente es
una información muy precisa a lo mejor
sí lo es para empresas que son muy
importantes porque se realiza una gran
cantidad de transacciones pero si tienes
una empresa que hace poquitas
transacciones al día pues a lo mejor
esta presión no refleja muy bien las
preferencias de mercado pero bueno esta
vista no me quiero meter no me quiero
meter mucho con eso con términos de
volumen después vamos a hacer una serie
de vídeos que platiqué acerca de eso
pero supongamos que ahorita el precio en
este preciso momento te metes a yahoo y
aquí hoy en este momento
hoy ahorita ahora
el precio de cada acción de la compañía
es de 15 pesos 15 pesos
supongamos además que esta empresa en
total ha emitido un millón de acciones
y entonces con esto qué información
tenemos pues mira el mercado está
diciendo que cada acción vale 15 pesos
hay un comprador y un vendedor que están
dispuestos a hacer la transacción a ese
precio y hay un millón de acciones en la
empresa entonces eso quiere decir que el
mercado está valuando este lado
izquierdo bueno está evaluando de este
lado derecho de la hoja de balance en 15
millones de pesos
voy a poner aquí 15 millones de pesos
y como no tenemos nada de deuda también
está valuando el lado izquierdo de la
empresa o sea el activo aquí está el
activo
activo y por acá está el capital también
lo está valuando en 15 millones de pesos
voy a poner aquí 15 millones pero bueno
supongamos que la empresa pues necesita
un poco más de dinero y entonces el
director de finanzas empieza a pensar
que tienen que hacer entonces tiene dos
opciones y esto es pues una gran parte
del trabajo del director de finanzas
tiene que decidir si financiar con
capital o financiar con deuda entonces
el director se pone a pensar no sabe muy
bien necesitan más dinero y entonces
digamos que necesitan cinco millones de
pesos más le voy a poner por aquí
5 millones 5 millones que se necesitan y
entonces ahora lo que tiene que hacer el
director de la empresa es pues platicar
con con la mesa directiva decirle
necesitamos financiarnos y puede decidir
financiar con capital o con deuda
supongamos que hace los dos para que
veamos que no que no tiene que hacer eso
de una sola forma entonces lo que puede
hacer el director de la empresa es decir
bueno comienza la mesa directiva emiten
más acciones
y digamos que emiten 200.000 va lo voy a
poner aquí 200 mil acciones entonces si
el precio por acción está de a 15 pesos
200 por 15 a lo mejor baja un poquito el
precio por acción porque ya aumentamos
la cantidad de acciones y estamos
saturando el mercado pero supongamos que
se quede en 15 entonces 200 por 15 son
quedaría 300 le voy a poner aquí son 3
millones que iba a poner el rectángulo
quedaría tres millones de pesos
en efectivo que se obtienen a través de
acciones ok entonces ya obtuvo un poco
vendiendo un poco más de capital
emitiendo un poco más de acciones pero
la empresa quería generar en total 5
millones o más bien quería recaudar 5
millones para continuar con sus
operaciones así que el director de
finanzas puede decirle a la mesa
directiva mira pues en realidad no fue
suficiente y ahora vamos a financiarnos
con deuda entonces vamos a ponerle que
hace eso que ya o sea que es una empresa
pues bien establecida que está
realizando cierto valor y entonces ya
puede pues ir con un banco y decirle
sabes que mira ya me financia un poquito
con capital pero necesito un empujoncito
más entonces van a ir a su banco
preferido
y luego van a tener que emitir deuda
entonces voy a ponerle por acá en color
rojo
otro cachito más más o menos algo de ese
estilo del otro lado del lado izquierdo
tenemos más activo tenemos dos millones
más y ya con eso se juntan los dos
millones
y después de ahí se va a tener que
empezar a pagar esta deuda de acá esta
deuda correspondiente a 2 millones de
pesos y la forma de pagar esta deuda
pues puede ser este muy variado
o sea se puede pagar ya sea hasta el
final del plazo o bien se puede ir
pagando en distintos periodos y hasta el
final pagar la cantidad principal
entonces hay varias formas en las cuales
se puede hacer esto de de ir pagando la
deuda bueno vamos a platicar ahorita
nada más un poquito más acerca de los
distintos conceptos de valor de empresa
o de cómo podemos decir cuánto vale una
empresa en términos de esto que ya
tenemos por acá entonces uno que ya
platicamos es el valor este de acá en la
que la capitalización del mercado que es
cuando dice el mercado que vale el
capital entonces déjame lo escribo por
acá abajo por un lado tenemos la
capitalización de mercado capitalización
de mercado que es cuánto vale el capital
según el mercado va entonces le voy a
poner aquí capital
y en este caso ya vimos cuánto es aquí
el capital pues sigue bueno aquí ya
cambia un poquito verdad porque aumentó
en 200 mil acciones entonces de este
modo pues cuanto dice el mercado que va
el capital que serían estos 15 millones
con estos 3 millones así que ahorita el
capital vale 18 millones de pesos
y eso es insisto es lo que dice el
mercado que vale el lado azulito de acá
pero hay otro concepto que contempla un
poco esto de la deuda y que contempla el
valor del empleo de la empresa incluido
este activo de por acá que se llama el
valor empresarial entonces lo escribo de
este lado también está el valor
empresarial y empresarial
qué es eso sea realmente cuánto vale la
empresa entonces aquí nada más es que el
capital pero acá la pregunta es cuánto
vale la empresa con todo y todo
entonces osea acordándonos un poquito de
nuestra hoja de balance tenemos que si
al lado izquierdo es el activo y el lado
derecho tiene en el pasivo y el capital
entonces tenemos que activo es igual a
pasivo más capital
y básicamente bueno ahorita lo vamos a
pensar así porque no quiero meterme en
muchos detalles pero básicamente el
valor empresarial es el lado izquierdo
es el lado izquierdo quitándole el
efectivo porque pues el efectivo
bueno el efectivo que no se usa para las
operaciones no es parte de la empresa
entonces básicamente en este caso
tendríamos un valor empresarial de 15
más 5 millones lo voy a poner por acá
entonces el valor empresarial sería de
20 millones y le voy a poner una
estrellita para acordarnos que tenemos
después que restar
estar
efectivo se sale entonces estas son dos
nociones para poder decir cuánto vale
una empresa uno es cuánto vale su
capital y el otro es el valor
empresarial cuánto valen todos los
activos que está utilizando y para eso
para calcular el valor empresarial
debemos de tomar la capitalización de
mercado sumarle la deuda que tiene la
empresa y finalmente tenemos que restar
el efectivo pero eso lo vamos a hacer en
otra serie de vídeos de valor
empresarial bueno espero que este vídeo
te haya ayudado un poco entender estas
dos formas de financiamiento en el
siguiente nos vamos a meter un poco más
con un poco en cosas un poquito de
acciones y de bonos nos vemos hasta la
próxima